[Music]
[Applause]
he's Ross Tucker he's a special offer to
this program Ross Tucker football
podcast and guess who has the
opportunity to witness that incredible
powerful Iowa offense noon Eastern on
CBS Ross Tucker will be on the call Iowa
against
Nebraska Ross man are you
lucky you ready for all the the
superlatives you're going to be saying
about that Iowa offense historically the
worst offense in the history of college
football and they're nine-
two with with a chance to go 10- two and
then play in the Big 10 championship
game next week against Ohio State or
Michigan it's really remarkable I mean
they're so good on defense and special
teams that they've been able to overcome
as you referenced one of the worst
offens we've ever seen in college
football it's really remarkable I mean
you look at these other teams and they
might win like two games where they scor
less than 20 points iow was won five
games where they've scored less than 20
points they win seemingly every close
game they're four- one in one score
games and you know they had this video
of their punter Tory Taylor in the last
game the home game where he was like
coming out of the tunnel Dan it looked
like the Joe burrow video at
LSU like like the Heisman hyp video
except for Iowa it's their punter and I
asked a buddy of mine I'm like was that
like a joke or are like do people really
love him that much like no no we we we
realized how valuable the punter is and
that was not a joke that was sincere and
genuine that's how much we love that
dude he's the big reason why we win
games and the
Nebraska let me ask you about the
college rankings that came out your
resume versus you know an injury here
like Florida State should they drop
should they have dropped uh and should
you factor in the injury to Jordan
Travis who's their Star Quarterback gone
for the year no I don't think you should
factor in the injury I don't think
that's fair to all the other guys on
that team I think it will be factored in
based on how they play in their next two
games right like how they play against
Florida and how they play against
Louisville in the ACC Championship then
you'll have a better idea of what they
are but don't preemptively do it right
that doesn't make sense maybe their
backup quarterback's awesome maybe comes
out and plays great I don't understand
the logic of like a preemptive strike
now if you moved up Washington because
they beat Oregon State and it was an
impressive win and now they got these
impressive wins which they do against
Oregon and Utah and Oregon State totally
fine with that but it should not have
been because Travis got hurt I'm not a
fan of that well you have this in the
SEC where you'll play a cupcake and and
they allow this because I think you play
eight games against SEC opponents now
this is in Florida State but Florida
State you're playing North
Alabama uh you know so that's where it's
hard to sometimes sympathize where
Washington and Oregon are playing
against quality opponents you know Pack
12 week in and week out the Big 10 you
have to play the Big 10 schedule there
uh so I I think sometimes these teams
hurt themselves because they're going to
play against somebody that they should
beat 58
to10 yeah well and and to your point Dan
I mean the big 10 you got to play nine
conference games in the SEC they said
that's not going to be good for us if we
want to make the college football
playoff why do we want to have one more
game where we're we're smashing against
each other let's have that game before
the rivalries where we play you know an
FCS school or play play a lesser school
and I do think that's probably one of
the reasons why the SEC has had so many
teams go to the college football playoff
and so many years where they have two
that's one less game Dan that's losable
right even if they're probably gonna
beat Kentucky or Arkansas whoever else
it would be it's still one less game
that's actually losable they're not
going to lose you know against these FCS
teams we're talking to Ross Tucker
Westwood One CBS Sports NFL college
football analyst and of course a former
offensive lineman uh if I gave you CJ
stad or Trevor Lawrence the rest of
their
careers oh that is a good one I think
I'd go CJ Stout W yeah I think I'd go CJ
Stroud just because let's go by the body
of work and the sample size we have so
far right you know even just this year
Dan I think that strads probably
objectively played better than Lawrence
has
this is year three for Lawrence and I
don't know that he was playing that
great now he's coming off his best game
against the Titans give him credit for
that but the week before against the
Niners he didn't look very good and I
think he's got significantly better
people around him than stad does in
other words I don't know that the Texans
are six and four with Trevor Lawrence
like they are with Stroud and I'm pretty
confident that jaguars would be seven
and three if strad was there so I'll
take Stroud because his be it an
admittedly limited sample size so far is
better than I think Lawrence's entire
body of work how good do you feel as a
eagle fan with that performance against
Kansas City because if Valdez scantling
hangs on to the football then we got a
lot of questions about the Eagles so
they they survived they won in Kansas
City but how do you feel about
them well I think you feel great that
they found a way to win the game like
they so often do and that they still
have pole position for the number one
seed I really don't think we talk about
it enough Dan you know I don't know any
other sport where the number one seed to
me it's inequitable I mean not only are
you the only team that doesn't have to
play a game that first weekend but then
you get two home games I mean the
difference between the one seed and the
two seed they could have the same record
Dan and the one seed just has to play
two games at home whereas the two seed
has to play three games including one on
the road so if you're an Eagles fan yeah
I mean it was strange quite frankly to
see the Chiefs probably be better than
the Eagles up front on both sides of the
ball I thought the chiefs were the
better team in that game but ultimately
nobody really cares all that matters is
the win loss what matters is who plays
better when they face each other again
in the playoffs if that's what happens
but getting that number one seed is so
critical that I think you feel real good
about the Eagles chances to still secure
that because they got a win that they
kind of weren't supposed to get right
they were the underdogs in the game they
kind of stole one and with these other
tough games coming up Buffalo San
Francisco at Dallas to kind of get that
win in their back pocket was huge yeah I
agree because you got to hold off the
Cowboys in your own Division and you
want to try to secure HomeField
Advantage as a former offensive lineman
tell me what happens in the brotherly
shove the tush push like what what is
your role as an an offensive guard you
know the center is the most important
but as a guard what role would you play
so by the way I'm glad you're bringing
this up because what the Eagles do is
incredibly impressive and I'm glad that
we've had a lot of season now or a
second season of them doing it so that
we see these other teams that can't do
it that well the best thing they have
going for them Dan it's the left side of
the line I mean Jordan Milad is 68 380
and then Lander Dickerson 66 probably
355 but I think the advantage there is I
think Milada with his rugby background
has helped Dickerson know the key is to
keep your feet moving those guys are
basically crawling they have their hands
down but they keep their butts up and
they keep their legs moving a lot of
times it's not the initial surge yeah
but because those guys in the left side
keep those legs and feet and their hands
moving it just becomes like a wave
because they're so big they're so strong
and they don't stop their feet I think
the D lineman sometimes stop their feet
and Herz rides that second wave Jason
Kelce will even be the first one to tell
you that he and Herz get the credit what
happens is there's an initial stalemate
but mil lad and Dickerson just keep
digging you know like the old bear crawl
and then Herz gets pushed and shoves
over to that side where there's always
push there's always separation I mean
they it looks like they get like two and
a half yards a carry on that thing but
now you have Defenders going over the
top which I don't understand that logic
that like they're trying to get Hertz
before he ducks for cover but it makes
it easier if I'm taking a a 64 you know
280 PB guy out of the equation in the
middle so I think the first worst level
guys need to try to jump the count and
just dive at the legs the feet of the
offensive lineman right so stop the pile
right there and then have your second
level guys the linebackers dive over the
top and try to hit Herz with a shot like
perie got in that Minnesota game they've
tried it it still hasn't worked but to
me that's that's your best opportunity
to try to slow it down I'm going to give
you one game to watch tomorrow in the
NFL
you can have the Packers Lions
commanders Cowboys Niners
Seahawks definitely not commanders
Cowboys okay the only reason why I I I
like Detroit is I just love their team I
I love like that place is going to be
going berserk tomorrow I'm so happy for
their fans I love Dan Campbell I love
their team I still think the best game
though is going to be San Francisco at
Seattle so I'll take the night cat
just because both teams are still very
much in the mix and I think it'll be a
good game I think Seattle's going to
give them everything they got yeah you
know I think that stands alone is the
best matchup but I think sentimental
value of tuning into those games that
start early in Detroit and you're just
it's a it's not pretty they usually lose
uh the Highlight is John Madden calling
the game but this is different like now
you have a real reason to tune in
because this isn't the only time you're
going to watch watch the Lions since
2000 this is the eighth time the Lions
have took a uh taken a winning record
into Thanksgiving and they're four and
three in those previous seven
Thanksgiving game um let me see I got
something else here um the last time the
Lions took a record of eight and two or
better into their Thanksgiving game was
1962 and they beat the Packers that day
2614 though maybe uh little Karma yeah
I'm I'm so happy for them we had so many
years D where we would say is it fair
that the Lions get the Thanksgiving Day
game every year because everybody hated
watching the Lions it was always a
terrible game they stunk I'm glad that
they're good and the Thanksgiving Day
game is just awesome I had the privilege
of 21 years ago starting for the Cowboys
against Washington and still a top five
game top five uh football experience in
my life because everybody you know is
watching I think it's like
other than the Super Bowl it might be
like the best ratings everybody you know
is watching and what's really cool as a
player Dan you know you get the weekend
off so literally back in 2002 I flew
home the next morning on Friday morning
and that night was my fifth year high
school reunion I started for the Cowboys
the day before my fifth year high school
reunion like I I couldn't have planned
that any better any girl that didn't
like me in high school I was like hi
Barbara oh okayy Jessica how was your
Thanksgiving yeah nice it was amazing it
was like a dream but it was weird that
you wore your uniform to your fiveyear
anniversary just to let people remind
them you're eye black there you walk in
hey you know what's funny Dan true story
some kid I didn't like I'm at my fifth
year some kid I didn't like he he he
brought up the fact that I gave up a
sack to Bruce Smith he was like oh I saw
you give up a sack to Bruce Smith
yesterday I was like who Matt who do you
play for like what like really
I man you know you know I'm at a reunion
I'm probably five beers deep like hey
Matt that's that's a that that's a great
opportunity to get punched in the face
maybe don't say
that oh safe travels buddy Happy
Thanksgiving all right likewise see you
guys that's uh Ross
Tucker a great opportunity to get punch
in the face five beers deep uh he's got
Nebraska and Iowa that's noon Eastern on
CV he's great he really is he's a
wonderful person uh